charlottesville had you know with with
that with with the initial purpose of
protecting the statue was a good thing I
don't I'm not a I don't know about
Confederacy except for the big thing but
honestly it's a it's a slippery slippery
slope and it the confused souls who in a
bad like this darkened souls for sure
not good they screwed up big time
because the purpose behind it is so
important because it's going to be
fought founding fathers next anyone who
ever contributed anything to one
civilization as we know it is already
being started being done James Madison
High School in the States is getting
renamed because some girls one student
felt unsafe and so yeah this is a
serious issue I want it like really feel
like we're really up against the wall
now because now they found their Nazis
man the Nazis are flooding the streets
now so how do we how do we possibly you
know kind of save our cakes
[Applause]
you had to bring it up didn't you well
having the right degenerated to the
identity politics does not seem to be a
positive solution so one of the things I
would say is that like I understand why
the identity politics that has been
practiced so assiduously and so
devastatingly by the left has been
co-opted by the right I understand that
but then here's what I would say to the
people on the right who are playing that
game if you play the game of your
enemies and you win you win their game
you don't win
that's not victory you just become the
most successful exponent of their
pathology well how is that a good thing
it's a bad thing so what does that leave
people as although as an alternative
well I don't think that
the Caucasians let's say should revert
to being white I think that's a bad idea
it's a dangerous idea and it's coming
fast and I don't like to see that I
think the whole group identity thing is
seriously pathological I think we've
made big mistakes in Canada I understand
why at least to some degree in that
respect and that large mistakes are
being made all over the Western world
where we're making your group identity
the most important thing about you
I think that's reprehensible I think
it's devastating
I think it's genocide 'el in its
ultimate expression I think it will
bring down our civilization if we pursue
it we shouldn't be playing that game so
what's the alternative you know I've
thought for a long time about a
political career really forever since I
was like 12 really for a long time and
I've always decided against it because
it seemed to me that the proper level of
analysis with regards to the solution of
the problem that we're facing isn't
political and that's why I think it's a
mistake when what I'm doing
gets politicized either by me or others
I think that the way that you deal with
this is to put yourself together I
really believe that is that because I
think that individual people are far
more powerful they're certainly far more
evil than they're willing to consider
but that's also a sign of their
unbelievable power so I think that what
you do is you aim high and put yourself
together and stay the hell away from the
ideologues because they're hiding
they're hiding behind a wall they're not
able to come out and fight on their own
behalf and so the way forward through
the ideological mess and that's the
lesson of Western culture is to place
the individual at the place of paramount
importance and to make the group
identity emerge only when necessary and
secondarily
if ever and so you can do that you can
do that now you can do that tomorrow
like you can put your life together and
again as I mentioned to the other young
man who asked the question is you won't
hurt any
doing that right you pick up your
goddamn responsibilities sort yourself
out fix up your family right and then
you can be a force for good in the
culture and if enough people do that the
ideological mess will just evaporate
it'll just disappear I think that's the
way you show people the right path
forward to is that you say well look um
we would like we would like it so much
if you could thrive as an individual
drop your cult-like affiliation right
step out of the shadows the demonic
shadows your ideological possession and
step forward as a fully developed person
into the light do it by example that's
your that's your best bet man so that's
what it looks like to me
[Applause]